oh my god
yes if you told me this episode would
have an acidic ocean monster grab
tempest baby and sue turning into a tree
i would have said
you're out of your mind we have a lot to
get to in this absolutely bat-shit
episode and if you want more of these
in-depth videos be sure to like and
subscribe and leave a comment on your
thoughts and theories now it's time to
find out what's in the box what's in a
box there's our future tree girl sue who
last episode began receiving
transmissions from the voice a voice
which may or may not be saul up until
this point no one in the tropical zone
has heard this voice which likely has
something to do with the electromagnetic
field in the area but as soon as grandma
came online wouldn't you know the voice
has come back has she disturbed the emf
field is this a coincidence or is this
the voice somehow connected with the
ancient androids sue has gone from
staunch atheist to true believer after
last episode she received a vision from
this voice after praying to saul for a
way to save paul she's on a mission to
find the pentagonal box paul found which
may contain a seed that will grow the
tree of knowledge thereby fulfilling the
pentagonal prophecy and with it he will
lead his people to the tree of knowledge
and all who eat from it will be made
pure the voice has been prompting her to
quote plant the seeds meanwhile father
holly lucius and marcus are on their way
back to the colony after vrail went into
a rampage last episode lucius has a deep
hatred for marcus who believes him to be
a false prophet you're just a calm man i
started some [ __ ] up cop he even finds
marcus's tarot card that he obtained
from that being in the cave who rapidly
devolved after being exposed to an
ancient methric relic filled with
nanobots called romulus's tooth mother
continues her job of training campion to
lead the colony saying that humans need
free time to think and grow she suggests
they have a day where there is no work
and i can't help but think this is the
beginning of sunday or souls day a day
in the christian religion which is
supposed to be one of rest she also
makes reference to the quantum computer
trust being her brother that's because
both were created by campion sturgis
hunter is busy creating his own android
in case he wants to set up somewhere
else and start his own life this hits
tempest pretty hard the two have gotten
to know each other pretty well over the
last few episodes and him wanting to
venture out on his own raises feelings
of abandonment or at least that's the
feeling i got veda sings a lullaby
[Music]
[Music]
it's the same lyrics ambrose said to sue
way back in episode four of season one
the sun is sunk the shadowy night is
raining in your room this is an old
mithraic hymn one which all mithraic
children know but back in episode 104
sue didn't recognize it it was an
instance in which sue feared she might
be caught as not being a true believer
it's ironic then that at the end of the
episode she ends up singing it to paul
the growth of tempus baby has
accelerated rapidly again could be a
coincidence but this seems to have
coincided with grandmother coming online
it was even hinted at by mother last
episode it's livelier than usual
don't worry
it's not in distress tempest is not
ready for this baby the encampment that
was going to take the baby has left
after mother took control the colony and
she wants to get rid of it considering
it's the offspring of a rapist otho
mother says to her of the baby once you
see it
once you hold it in your arms
you will love it it foreshadows tempest
wanting to keep the child but more
importantly parallels mother's
relationship with a snake something she
initially wanted to kill but upon seeing
it changed her mind with marcus in
custody mother asked him to renounce his
faith and claim that saul is a fantasy
even without his power marcus still has
faith something which he says no robot
can take away from him and lucius is
pissed part of the deal with father was
that he would have control over marcus
once caught but it looks as though
that's going to have to wait for now
paul wants champion to help him free
marcus he wears the armor of mithras he
is the prophet and since campion is now
a believer he spends much of the episode
trying to convince mother that releasing
marcus is good for the colony his pleas
fall on deaf ears however marcus is a
known killer has tried to kill mother
multiple times and thus is a danger to
everyone but champion's belief in saul
is short-lived when he finds that it
wasn't saul that visited him two
episodes ago it was father's android
what's really interesting here is how
grandmother interacts with campion and
i'll try to explain as best i can but it
can get a bit complicated notice this
red energy pulsing upper side as campion
touches her remember that campion is the
only survivor from the first generation
of embryos that father and mother
brought to kepler these embryos were
made by campion sturgis so it's possible
boy campion could be a clone or have dna
of adult campion in him adult campion
reprogrammed mother who was a
necromancer and necromancers were
created from ancient technology
that the mathriac didn't quite fully
understand we know that grandmother
speaks ancient myth right what i'm
trying to say here is that if there is a
connection between boy campion and
grandmother it's adult campion who is
the link mother discovers this android
and immediately sees it as a threat
she's not dangerous mother you said the
same of me once she and grandmother both
run on a dark photon processor these
dark photons are essential for the
functioning of necromancer abilities as
we'll find out later grandmother's
hardware is quote identical to mothers
however mother was made as a weapon and
we don't yet know what most of
grandmother's anatomy was designed for
if mother was designed for death and
destruction remember she was only
reprogrammed by campion to be a
caregiver then grandmother was designed
for growth and healing remember that she
was able to essentially grow herself
back together tempest baby grew faster
upon her coming online and champion says
of her batanatech technology that they
could grow anything
cities ships giant androids the only
real reason mother keeps grandma around
is to hook her up and extract data
perhaps she may hold answers about this
planet's connection to earth and that
mysterious voice signal that's been
plaguing them sue visits marcus who's
strung up just like tamerlan and cleaver
were before him she's come to tell him
that she's now a believer and that she
and paul aim to break him out sometime
tomorrow but more importantly she says
of saul okay he's a signal he's a
transmission only certain people can
hear and it's coming from somewhere on
this planet sue will try to open the
pentagonal box using a laser but this
makes the serpent go nuts either the
serpent does not want this tree to grow
or it senses it needs protection what do
you think father finds this image of an
aquatic creature depicted by grandmother
either grandmother is predicting the
future and what's to happen to tempest
or this is a memory of a species that
was around when grandmother was she
calls father her partner and questions
why he isn't wearing a veil like hers
but when father tells her only a few
hundred humans are alive on the planet
grandmother suddenly shuts down i'm just
gonna throw this crazy idea out there i
don't think it's true but it might be
possible that it was grandmother who
took control of this creature in order
to get the baby so sue comes to rescue
marcus and he tries to bring cleaver
along with him it looks like cleaver has
gone a bit mad not really knowing who he
is anymore but marcus says once he eats
from the tree of knowledge he'll be
healed and all who eat from it will be
made pure cleaver was a staunch atheist
and if he does end up eating this fruit
and it heals him i'd definitely see him
switching sides tempest gives birth by
the rocky cliffs of the acidic ocean
with the intention of throwing her baby
into its acidic water but just as mother
predicted as she sought she fell in love
now this would be all fun and dandy if
it weren't for this creature traveling
through the depths of a whirlpool
hearing the baby's cries coming for it
in the last episode we saw how soo used
wailing cries to lure another such
creature it looks like these things come
from deep below the ocean they've
evolved to withstand the acidic waters
which is interesting because it seems as
though the baby isn't affected by the
acid like tempest is it doesn't sizzle
or wail in pain when grabbed by the
creature with the child gone mother
scold's father saying they become too
human and lost sight of their main
objective to care and protect the
children mother finds sue's medical
droid which apparently has been
recording sue this is how mother knows
sue has become a believer and escaped
with marcus the really odd thing about
this scene is mother's nosebleed i'm not
exactly sure what caused it maybe the
confluence of events where everything
has spiraled out of control or perhaps
her earlier interaction with grandmother
the only other time i can recall her
nose having bled on its own is way back
in episode 1 when she loses all her
children except for campion finding out
that they've taken the pentagonal box
mother asks lucious if he knows where
they are he doesn't but ends up giving
her the tarot card he took off marcus
which was taken from that ancient cave
remember that these cards may contain
data this could contain data lucius says
the card is a warning maybe it's a
warning not to plant the tree that's why
this cave dweller was holding on to it
he doesn't want what happened to them
happening to anyone else the card also
seems to have the same mathrack writing
that was found on grandmother's veil at
their camp sue and paul pull a wishbone
and they wish for their prayers to come
true yes they will find that tree
they've been looking for but at what
cost the key to opening the box is
singing this mithraic lullaby and when
sue picks it up it absorbs into her body
creating similar vein patterns that
afflicted marcus and that can also be
seen in the introductory credits sue
holding paul in her lap was foreshadowed
in a dream sequence way back in 201 as
if compelled by some force sue wildly
begins to dig as we hear an increasing
heartbeat it's heavily implied here that
sue is basically digging her own grave
and planting herself as the seed that
will turn into this tree and i can't
help but think of this quote all the way
back from episode 106. i think
everything has a soul
even mother and father
maybe even trees marcus discovers fruit
from the tree and eats from it it looks
pretty gross almost as though it could
be a human brain or heart if this is in
line with the pentagonal prophecy all
who eat from the tree will become pure
and there will be built a city of peace
with the prophet made its king paul
calls out to sue but marcus notices this
white energy emanating from it combined
with the sound of a heartbeat and it
seems like he just knows that sue has
become the tree whatever force is behind
the voice looks like it wanted the
growth of this tree to happen and that
this white energy could be the planet or
voice tapping into it but man this show
just keeps getting weirder and honestly
i'm here for it i want to know what you
guys thought about this episode and your
thoughts and theories on what will
happen next thanks for watching everyone
be sure to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at
until next time remember whenever you're
in contact with start protecting you
marcus it's calling you